okay so Jason literally just picked up
this clown that you see that zombie Jake
on there and it was just pure
coincidence that that happened to be the
episode we were watching this is from
bad to worse and my voice sounds a
little bit I apologize I'm just an ass
see it's just sore and stuff so
so these part will be super long but
we'll do our best
um so this is from bad to worse and this
is a server rear end of the very first
episode all right well the Zandi of
Sandy that's zombie kandi is trying to
say there and pretty much it's happening
again
and they have to think up a formula and
bubblegum says you have to use science
so Jake and and Finn and I was yeah I
wasn't must say LSD it goes in there
and they all work in a formula each
formula makes the situation worse and
they're all getting bitten and finally
Finn figures out that science is a name
of the little candy corn rat so he lets
him out he's fix up a formula and saves
the day um opposed was gave up or
honestly it's like there are definitely
some fight scenes I like how all the
formulas make them worse that was funny
I love it when Jake kids bit and he
tries to outrun the the infection he
gets his arm longer and long I mean that
was great that's using the the Bower you
can do um and the fact that the rat was
science you know that that's cute you
know the lowly you know now it's get the
award Finn will you get out of the way
now to science that's like from that's
like I don't know it's and maybe if it
was something new like a different a
like a different zombie thing or a
different creator and something else
doing it but when it's like it's
happening again and we gotta make
another formula its I don't know there's
something about when I just hear another
and here we go again and so just for me
it's like they it's like well we saw
that why are we watching it again um and
how about the humor just seemed a touch
for a better time to seem a touch slower
no I agree like it seemed to step off
if
you will like something would happen and
it's like almost the comedy was a step
behind what was going on
yeah there you know with um in you know
were to ease you know when a joke would
happen particularly no person movies
since W you'll know this like he'll do a
joke and they'll wait a second for like
the laugh to set in for people to laugh
and stuff like that and that way sort of
slowly dying out because humor is quick
now and we're so used to it so we throw
a lot at the camera fast and Bexar time
has done that uh but with this way it's
sort of had like that humor like deliver
the joke sir wait a second and take its
time and I I guess they're maybe trying
to create a little bit more atmosphere
with like how creepy they are maybe I
don't know I because there there were
some like like it's much for kid show I
mean there were some kind of creepy
scenes I mean like where they're quite
not a bit much yeah maybe you see
bubblegum like transform you know just
sciences mom which we we all thought she
said mom Errol and yeah I just didn't I
don't know I couldn't get into this one
as much you uh it was fine
I do actually agree with you for the
most part it was kind of a letdown I
like zombies I'm a horror movie nut and
I mean you can only have the zombie time
glass exactly but I mean you can only
watch so many zombie films before it
kind of gets the point where it's like
yeah I've kind of been down this road
before and on a TV show you can only do
it even less than that it's hard to kind
of reach Fred the same thing like with
the last with the creeps
the one where did where they did the
murder it reminded me of that one but
they added something new
exactly least on that one they kind of
added something new they tossed out
something that kept you interested this
was kinda like oh okay okay look Canella
spean lips it was even like the lip
thing yeah it's like wasn't that funny
it's funny unless you go out there and
try to lick up the formula to get lips
and stuff I mean it's yeah I know what
you're saying like you're expecting
something even funny
here yeah yeah this and maybe adventure
times just raise the bar too high but do
i I do agree with some of the creepy
moments like I love when Jake is in the
science II shower I think it was and he
starts unwrapping yeah I do it I'm like
that was kind of cool you know he was
already zombified and all that stuff but
it was very nicely done I like that um
the part for me that I was like oh my
god that's gotta suck is when Finn tries
to formula on Jake and Jake translate
back to dog again it's like oh sweet oh
yeah I mean that was gonna that's a good
joke I mean much would that suck I'm
human I'm dead again yeah it was kind of
like you don't you know and the thing
with I guess I was can't wait for a joke
here you got a lady unicorn who's
Rainicorn Rainicorn sorry uh Lady
Rainicorn who's kind of pointless in
this one like I don't think she does
like I love like you Rainicorn enjoys
over there like but she's got an
appointment in this one you know and the
only thing they ever do is that when
Jake is the zombie in the shower he says
you know they don't open it it's not him
I know it looks like him but it's not
him
and she just opens it and there's no
reason why I couldn't the Samba get like
the big sad eyes or the puppy-dog eyes
are saying couldn't he do something
different something funny to make her
open the door and stuff everywhere just
open it alone were you gonna say
something she says I love you in Korean
so she's talking to him through the
showers so she opens it wait I said so
you're saying like she's like I can't
live without you we'll both be zombies
was that know I don't know I'm just
saying like she says the word I love you
so you know Oh even better
you just watch out the one word that you
knew is I can't do it there was I think
it was just just finit mentioned
something about you know even though he
might look like the Jake you used to
love he's not the Jake anymore he's just
a Zambian
yeah what we saw to we I I you're not
even on camera why we listen to you
I almost take it more from there
attacking or going after the cliche yeah
Ted they specifically state that and the
original they're saying how they may
look like the person you love but
they're not Bobby couldn't add another
thing can they ever just go like that or
just something funny you know this opens
the door and I don't know I I agree I'm
not I'm not arguing or saying you're
wrong I'm just saying I think that's
what they were more going for but they
kind of dropped the ball the only thing
I could figure is that maybe maybe when
they did the first episode they either
people either complain or they said to
themselves wait one be cool if we did
that like a real zombie movie or like Oh
real zombies in there because in the
first one it's kind of like just oh just
kind of keep everybody distracted don't
actually let them know that song you
know how you don't see much of the
zombies we're in this one it's like okay
this is a send-up to zombies this is
obviously you know following the cliches
and stuff but yeah it's kind of like it
does seem like they do like that many
plenty things with them at least for
adventure type you know ah because I
usually have stuff a lot faster a lot
quicker so um but yeah that happens
every once a while it it definitely
happens so um well that voice of yours
being gone definitely did not stop you
from talking yeah I'm kind of amazed you
know just really it's it's where I can't
do see that let me try to do a high
voice like that was me doing that yeah
see I can't do that I want a recording
of that no yeah yes